Scheisse.
Oh, oh.
Ich muss nach Hause.
- Warum?
Scheisse. Kannst du mir helfen?
- Sicher, stell es auf den Boden.
Was ist passiert?
- (Frau) Steck sie aus.
Auswanderin Marina
ist von oben bis unten
mit Haselnusscréme vollgespritzt.
In der Restaurantküche
eine riesige Sauerei.
Und in 30 Min.
ist Eröffnung ihres Waffelshops.
Neue Heimat Florida.
Mike Hostettler und seine Frau Marina
Marrer wollen in den USA
ein Waffelrestaurant eröffnen.
Für ihren Traum vom Leben in den USA
verlassen sie die Heimat
im Berner Oberland.
Die Schweiz ist zu klein
und nichts von der ganzen Welt.
Ich war schon früher immer
der Indianer- und Cowboyfreak.
In Tampa mieten der ehemalige
Polizist und die Produktmanagerin
ein Ladenlokal
und lassen es komplett umbauen.
Ich habe noch nie
ein solches Business betrieben.
Ich bin etwas ...
... nervös.
You can have the waffle with:
Hershey's, Reese's, Oreos, Twix,
Snickers, KitKat.
Das Geschäft
mit dem Süssgebäck läuft gut an,
aber die viele Arbeit
hinterlässt Spuren.
Mike schlittert in ein Burn-out.
Mein Körper sagte im Laden:
"Stopp, zu viel des Guten."
Wenn wir hier aufgeben müssten,
hätten wir nichts mehr.
Und dann ...
... ja.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Winter 2020.
Willst du es so oder so?
Lieber so.
- So.
Schon in wenigen Wochen geht es los.
Die letzte Kundin
auf meinem Schragen.
Sehr speziell.
Tätowieren ist Mikes Leidenschaft.
Eine Passion, die er abends
und am Wochenende ausübt.
Denn seine sicheren Jobs
wollte er bisher nicht aufgeben.
17 Jahre lang arbeitete als Polizist.
Zuletzt war er Leiter Verkehrstechnik
in Thun.
Amerika ist seit bald 20 Jahren ...
... ein Traum.
Ich war schon früher immer
der Indianer- und Cowboyfreak.
Die Route 66
hat mich immer fasziniert.
Das ist von Jahr zu Jahr
immer mehr gewachsen.
Jetzt mit 43 möchte Mike seinen Traum
nicht mehr länger aufschieben
und wagt den Neuanfang in Florida.
Hopp, hopp.
Mit seiner 29-jährigen Frau Marina
setzt Mike alles auf eine Karte:
In das Waffelrestaurant
werden sie fast ihre
gesamten Ersparnisse investieren.
Der Traum Amerika
kommt eher von Mike.
Aber für mich war
einfach schon immer klar,
dass ich nicht ewig
am gleichen Ort bleiben will.
Ich möchte Neues erleben,
neue Leute kennenlernen.
Möglichst viel erleben im Leben.
Die Schweiz ist zu klein.
Die Schweiz ist nichts
von der ganzen Welt.
Komm.
Lange fehlte Marina und Mike
die passende Geschäftsidee,
die sie zum Einwandern in die USA
brauchten.
Der Zufall brachte den Stein
schliesslich ins Rollen.
Djuni.
In Bern besuchten die beiden
ein Waffelrestaurant
einer Gastronomiekette.
Diese suchte selbstständige Partner,
sog. Franchisenehmer.
Marina und Mike bewarben sich
und so kam eines zum anderen.
Wir haben beide noch nie
in einem Restaurant gearbeitet.
Aber dadurch,
dass es ein Franchisesystem ist,
bekommt man natürlich Hilfe.
Dann müssen wir einen Kurs machen,
um in Amerika
ein Restaurant führen zu dürfen.
Da lernen wir auch viel.
So, das muss reichen.
Hast du die Richtige?
- Ja, schon.
Waffeleisen anstatt Tätowiernadel:
Ihre zukünftigen Kunden
wollen Mike und Marina
unter der heissen Sonne Floridas
empfangen.
Am liebsten duschen, Tasche packen
und ab in den Flieger.
Geht's?
- Ja.
Kommt schon gut.
Dann heisst es für Mike und Marina
Abschied nehmen.
Schon in 2 Std.
sitzen sie im Flugzeug.
(Frau) Ihr meldet euch, gell?
Ja. Sobald wir dort sind,
rufen wir an.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Am Morgen um 0.30 Uhr
hört ihr von uns. - Ist gut.
Mike, mach's gut.
Danke für alles.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Tampa, Florida.
Gleich nach ihrer Ankunft hissten
die beiden die Berner Flagge.
Mittlerweile
leben sie schon drei Monate hier.
Die ist von unserer Familie
und unseren Freunden.
Dort sind Sprüche drauf
und jeder hat unterschrieben.
Die bedeutet uns sehr viel.
Und natürlich eine Berner Flagge
für uns als Berner.
Solothurn würde auch passen, Schatz,
weiss und rot.
Nein,
das wäre zu viel rot und weiss.
Allein schon das Geräusch, Schatz.
Von diesem Ding.
* Klackern *
Das würdest du vermissen.
- Ja.
Das möchtest du nicht mehr missen.
Es ist einfacher,
um Mojito zu machen.
In den Filmen aus Amerika
ist es immer so cool,
wenn die Leute zum Kühlschrank gehen
und Eis rauslassen.
Das ist ein Bruchteil
des American Dream.
Florida.
Sunshine pur.
Fünf Autominuten
von zu Hause entfernt
haben Mike und Marina das Geschäfts-
lokal für ihren Waffelshop gemietet.
Dieses befindet sich -
so richtig amerikanisch –
in einer Mall:
dem Grand Plaza Shopping Center.
* Gelassene Klänge *
Und zwar genau hier.
Ursprünglich glaubten die beiden,
dass sie ihr Restaurant zwei Monate
nach Ankunft in den USA eröffnen.
Aber wegen Corona
dauerte es nur schon drei Monate,
bis sie die Bewilligungen
für den Umbau erhielten.
Dann waren Baumaterialien
kaum zu bekommen,
und Handwerker fielen Corona-bedingt
immer wieder aus.
Sie wären hier, es brennt Licht,
die Maschinen sind bereit ...
... aber es ist 12.15 Uhr,
die sind beim Essen.
Welcher Boden geht bis dort hinten?
- Bis hier.
Der gleiche?
Dann legt er hier Fliessen.
Dann kommt das Elektrische
und die Wände davor.
Ein grosser Teil ihres Ersparten
steckt nun in diesen Wänden.
Das Alu, das auf dem Boden liegt,
dann kommt das Elektrische rein,
dann die Decke drauf.
Der Umbau im Laden rund 70'000 $.
Mhm.
Dazu kommt das ganze Equipment,
die Möblierung und Deko.
Alles in allem,
über den Daumen gepeilt,
kostet uns rund 200'000 Fr.
Da werden wir uns bewegen.
Bis wir endlich starten können.
Wir müssen ihn fragen.
Perfect.
Jetzt wird's laut.
Ich gehe zur Seite.
Nicht nur auf der Baustelle -
auch in Sachen Bewilligungen
gibt es viel zu tun.
Denn um ein Restaurant zu führen,
muss man in Florida
eine Prüfung ablegen.
Themen sind: Hygiene, Sicherheit,
Viren und Bakterien im Gastgewerbe.
Das müssen wir bestehen,
wir haben etwas Druck.
Die beiden müssen auch
die Finanzen im Griff haben.
Marina ist gelernte Kauffrau.
Ihr Wissen kann sie nun
im eigenen Business anwenden.
Noch aber
unterstützt sie Buchhalter Ken.
Yes.
Ich muss viel lernen.
Doppelte Buchhaltung
ist schon lange her.
Aber ich mache es gerne
und es interessiert mich.
Ich möchte den Überblick haben.
Ich will wissen,
wo was hingeht und warum.
Wo kann man Kosten einsparen,
damit man genügend Umsatz macht?
Du bist froh.
Ich bin froh, dass ich mich
nicht damit rumschlagen muss.
Ich verstehe nur Bahnhof.
Ich tue nur so,
als ob ich es verstehen würde.
Nein, es ist gut so, wie es ist.
Wir haben das klar aufgeteilt.
Dann erzählst du mal etwas
und ich tue so,
als ob es mich interessieren würde.
Als Franchisenehmer müssen
die beiden künftigen Gastronomen
die Einrichtungsvorgaben
des Hauptgeschäfts einhalten.
Und monatlich eine Gebühr bezahlen.
Du kannst dich hinsetzen.
Im Gegenzug können sie das Know-how
eines erfolgreichen und erprobten
Geschäftsmodells nutzen.
Es ist gar nicht
so unbequem ohne ...
... Kissen.
So sieht unser Laden
hoffentlich diesen Sonntagabend aus,
Also in vier Tagen.
Wegen der Pandemie kam der Umbau
ihres Waffelshops lange kaum voran,
die Jungunternehmer
verloren viel Zeit und Geld.
Doch diese frustrierenden Monate
sind endlich Geschichte.
Gerade noch rechtzeitig kamen
auch Marinas Prüfungsergebnisse.
Das ist Schweiss, purer Schweiss.
Ich habe Blut geschwitzt.
Man muss den Foodmanager haben.
Ich habe wirklich gezittert,
ob ich bestehe oder nicht.
Jetzt hat es geklappt.
Das ist wichtig.
Ohne das dürfen wir nicht eröffnen.
Haben wir alles?
- Ich glaube.
Letztes Mal erschraken sie,
als ich hinten reinkam.
Jetzt noch einmal Werbung machen.
Sie verteilen Einladungen
zur Eröffnung.
Hello, just one moment.
L-E
- B-R-O-N.
Thank you.
- See you, bye-bye.
* Gelassene Klänge *
Und dann ist es so weit.
Der Tag der Eröffnung ist da.
Die Schweizer am Cottontail Place
haben kaum geschlafen,
so nervös sind sie.
Es ist etwas komplett Neues.
Wir arbeiten jetzt
das erste Mal im eigenen Geschäft.
Dann auch der Kundenkontakt.
Ich kann schon Englisch,
aber es macht mich trotzdem nervös.
Wer kommt alles,
kommen viele, kommen wenige?
Kommen überhaupt Leute?
Es sollten schon Leute kommen.
Ja, man weiss es ja nie, darum ...
Um Hündin Djuna
kümmert sich heute die Nachbarin.
Mike hatte
bis spät in die Nacht gearbeitet
und war vor Tagesanbruch
wieder im Laden.
Für Marinas Zertifikat
hat er den geeigneten Platz gefunden.
Marina ist
unterdessen auf Einkaufstour,
begleitet von Yves Staub.
Auch Yves ist in die USA ausgewandert
und Partner derselben Gastrokette.
Mit dabei sind auch Chiara
und ihr jüngerer Bruder Nico.
Sie sind Yves Kinder.
Als letztes erteilt Yves Marina
und Mike die wichtigste Lektion:
das Teig rühren.
Hast du sie gefunden?
- Sure.
Jedem Teigkübel
wird eine vom Franchise-Geber
eigens zusammengestellte
Gewürzmischung beigegeben.
Ein Geheimrezept.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was drin ist.
Wirklich nicht. Nein.
Ich weiss es auch nicht 100%ig.
So ungefähr, aber ...
Aber man muss es auch nicht wissen.
Wichtig ist,
dass es am Schluss schmeckt.
So lange rühren,
bis es keine Klumpen mehr hat.
Du siehst, er wird etwas zähflüssig.
Rühren mit dem Bohrer.
So einfach wie das ausschaut,
ist es dann doch nicht.
Marina lernt ihre Lektion.
Scheisse.
Oh, oh.
Ich muss nach Hause.
- Warum?
Scheisse. Kannst du mir helfen?
- Sicher, stell es auf den Boden.
(Frau) Steck sie aus.
Scheisse.
- Der Boden ist sowieso schmutzig.
Von oben bis unten
mit Haselnusscreme vollgespritzt.
Zum Glück ist Marina
in einer Viertelstunde zu Hause.
Hast du alle Stöpsel rausgenommen?
Dieser Deckel muss endlich weg.
10 Min. vor dem Opening
die nächste Panne.
Jetzt reicht's dann,
das ist das zweite Übel heute.
Jetzt reicht's dann.
Damit
kommst du nicht vorwärts, Schatz.
Ich weiss es nicht.
- Bring mir einen Besen.
Wo ist unser Putzzeug?
Merci.
Wenn das über den Boden vorne läuft,
ist er am Arsch.
Sobald es über den Deckel geht,
kommt es gerade nach vorn.
Diese Schachtel schliessen,
auf die andere stellen,
mit den zwei Deckeln,
dann hinter den Fernseher stellen.
Der erfahrene Yves
bringt Ruhe in die Situation.
Hör auf. Geh dich umziehen,
zur Toilette. - Warum?
Weil es bald losgeht.
Damit wir um 17 Uhr
sicher bereit sind.
Wir machen das hier noch.
Aber 10 Min. reichen nicht mehr,
um mich bereit zu machen.
Ach, komm.
Sich noch einmal so richtig herzen
bevor es losgeht.
Du wirst nervös, nicht?
- Mhm.
Oje. Das kommt schon gut.
Es wird alles gut.
Du bist nicht alleine,
wir sind nicht alleine.
Eins, zwei, drei.
(Alle) Yeah!
Das ist hier Tradition.
Es soll Glück bringen,
in Houston macht man das so.
An eine Wand tackern,
das soll Glück
und v.a. Geld bringen.
Vielen Dank.
Now it's open.
Werden die Nachbarn, die Bekannten,
die Presseleute kommen?
Kommen die Influencer,
die das Waffelrestaurant in
den sozialen Medien promoten sollen?
Klebt da jeweils
die Hälfte an der Scheibe?
Nein, ich würde es so machen:
Lass die Waffel hier. - Ja.
Geh nach unten mit dem Messer,
dreh hier oben, nimm es dann rüber.
Nico, zuerst Puderzucker und danach?
Zuerst Puderzucker, dann ...
Es ist extrem schwierig,
mit der Sauce zu schreiben.
Das glaube ich.
Es sieht schon geil aus.
Und zum ersten Mal
serviert Mike eine Waffel
als eigenständiger Unternehmer.
Meine erste!
Hi.
Nach all der Aufregung
und den Sorgen: Die Gäste sind da.
Noch wichtiger: Die Waffeln kommen
gut an, auch bei den Influencern.
Enjoy.
Bald schon brummt der Laden.
Thank you so much, have
a nice evening. Thank you, bye-bye.
Es ist fast 23 Uhr, als sich die
letzten Gäste auf den Heimweg machen.
Thank you so much.
- See you.
Jetzt noch Putzen und Kassensturz:
Fragt sich, wie viel
die beiden eingenommen haben.
* Der Drucker quietscht. *
Knapp 700 $.
Aber es muss sich noch rumsprechen.
Kannst du das bitte zählen?
- Okay.
700 $ -
nicht schlecht für den Anfang.
Zehn und Münzen.
Deine Tasche noch.
Hast du allen Abfall?
- Ja.
Gegen Mitternacht erst
geht's nach Hause.
* Reggae-Version
von Göläs "Uf u Dervo" *
Zehn Wochen sind seit
der gelungenen Eröffnung vergangen.
Mit jedem Tag sind Marina und Mike
routinierter geworden
und sind
im amerikanischen Alltag angekommen.
Der Morgenspaziergang ist der
einzige Moment der Ruhe für Marina.
Die beiden arbeiten unablässig.
14 Std. täglich,
sieben Tage die Woche.
Hi. You're welcome.
Have a great day. Thank you.
* Geschäftige Klänge *
You can have the waffle with:
Hershey's, Reese's, Oreos, Twix,
Snickers, KitKat,
Gummy bears, M&M's, Kinder bueno,
Kinder Riegel, Raffaelo, Rocher.
Und doch:
Trotz Begeisterung
und noch mehr Herzblut,
ihr Alltag ist kräfteraubend.
Im Moment heisst es
arbeiten, arbeiten, arbeiten
und noch einmal arbeiten.
Das wird irgendwann anders.
Unser grösstes Problem ist es,
Mitarbeiter zu finden,
die zuverlässig sind.
Dann hat man das Gefühl,
dass sie zuverlässig sind,
in der Woche darauf
ist es dann das pure Gegenteil.
Bei uns
ist es momentan etwas stressig,
allem gerecht werden zu können.
Wieder steckt den Jungunternehmern
ein 14-Std.-Tag in den Knochen.
Erst gegen 23 Uhr sind sie zu Hause.
Ein Fondue?
- Ein Fondue.
Hoppala.
Willst du heute
wieder mal Weingläser?
Aber bitte die für die Spülmaschine.
Seit bald einem Jahr ist das Haus
am Cottontail Place das Zuhause
der Florida-Auswanderer.
Das musst du noch auffüllen,
letztes Mal war es plötzlich aus.
Prost.
Es fehlt uns,
zwischendurch Freunde zu treffen.
Oder Zweisamkeit.
Freunde
werden im Moment vernachlässigt.
Aber die kommen ab und zu
in den Laden und essen eine Waffel.
Genau.
* Langsame, lateinamerikanisch
angehauchte E-Gitarrenklänge *
Es brennt.
Sie sind 24 Std. zusammen,
Abwechslung haben sie kaum.
Dazu kommt der Stress im Geschäft -
eine stete Herausforderung
für das Paar.
Auch wir haben mal Streit und sind
nicht immer der gleichen Meinung.
Aber das gehört zum Leben dazu.
Egal, ob Freundschaft,
Beziehung, Geschäftspartner.
Ich glaube,
wir haben die Balance gefunden
zwischen Geschäfts- und Ehepartnern.
Ich glaube, wir haben sie gefunden.
Fünf Monate lang hatten Marina
und Mike Seite an Seite gearbeitet.
Mit Erfolg: Das Geschäft boomt.
Doch nun -
von einem Tag auf den anderen -
steht Marina allein im Geschäft.
Seit Mike weg ist ...
... bin ich irgendwie ...
Es muss alles noch schneller gehen
als zu zweit.
100 Std. in der Woche ohne
einen einzigen freien Tag schuften,
und dies während Monaten.
Mike hatte einen Zusammenbruch.
Wie aus dem Nichts
hatte er eines Tages Panikattacken
und fühlte sich schwach.
"Stopp!" sagte der Arzt.
Dies seien
erste Anzeichen eines Burnouts.
Er verordnete ihm Ruhe
und Medikamente.
Seit Tagen ist er nun daheim.
Vor 14 Tagen
sagte mein Körper im Laden:
"Stopp, zu viel des Guten."
Mein Blutdruck stieg massiv
und sank nicht mehr.
Ich musste bzw. durfte mir
Ruhe gönnen.
Wir haben es so verknüpft, dass ich
14 Tage zu Hause bleibe und packe.
Schachteln füllen
und immer wieder eine Pause einlegen,
das geht.
Denn bald schon
werden die beiden auch noch umziehen.
Im Waffelshop trägt Marina
die Verantwortung nun allein.
Zuverlässiges Personal zu finden
ist nach wie vor schwierig.
Maddie ist Studentin.
Sie unterstützt Marina,
so oft sie kann.
Noch ist völlig unklar,
wie lange Mike ausfallen wird.
Letzte Woche haben wir es probiert,
da kam er mit
und half mir am Morgen vorbereiten.
Für mich war das eine Erleichterung.
Aber es ging dann nicht gut.
Trotzdem: Ich weiss, er ist hier,
er würde mir helfen,
aber mit gewissen Sachen
möchte ich ihn gar nicht belasten.
Jetzt ist wichtig,
dass er zur Ruhe kommt.
Can I call you back later?
Sorry, I'm pretty busy.
Or can you send me an e-mail?
Wirklich Ruhe
findet Mike aber bisher kaum.
Und jetzt ist auch noch Umzugstermin.
Nach einem Jahr in Tampa ziehen
die Auswanderer in ein anderes Haus.
Yes, Sir.
Für Mike trotz Stress
ein notwendiger Schritt.
Er verspricht sich viel
von diesem Umzug.
Irgendwie
ist es befreiend für mein Herz.
Ich kann nicht sagen, warum,
aber es ist ...
Als ob Druck von mir weicht.
Bye-bye Cottontail Place,
ein neues Kapitel der Florida-
Auswanderer kann beginnen.
Und, hopp.
Das neue Daheim liegt weiter nördlich
und ist ein Vorort von Tampa.
Ein kleiner Wald
liegt direkt vor ihrer Haustüre.
Hier ist alles noch ein wenig wilder.
Herfahren, aussteigen
und heimkommen.
Ich weiss nicht warum, es passt.
Ich fühle mich wohl,
es ist komplett was anderes,
man hat die Natur,
Freunde,
geniale Nachbarn, auch hier.
Es ist gross, heller,
es ist nicht so drückend.
Jetzt ist es gut.
Du strangulierst dich!
- They play.
Kaum eingezogen,
treffen sie bereits Nachbarn.
We'll have to go to ...
You guys bake waffles?
- Yes, waffles.
Der neue Wohnsitz der Auswanderer
liegt gut 30 Min.
von ihrem Geschäft entfernt.
Ein Klacks für US-Verhältnisse.
Meldest du dich?
- Ja.
Tschüss. Bye.
- Tschüss.
Auch nach dem Umzug
bleibt Mike weiterhin daheim.
Ihn plagen Schwindel
und Kopfschmerzen
und sein Nacken ist so verspannt,
dass ihm das Atmen
immer wieder Mühe bereitet.
Wie lange geht das noch?
Wie lange muss Marina
den Waffelladen alleine managen?
Zeitweise mag ich nicht mehr.
Wir haben uns einige Male
die Frage gestellt, wie weiter.
Wenn dann auch ich nicht mehr mag,
wer macht es dann?
Das ist dann ...
Wenn wir das hier aufgeben müssen,
haben wir nichts mehr.
Ja.
Es gibt nur eines: Durchbeissen
und hoffen, dass es reicht.
Mike beschliesst,
weitere Hilfe in Anspruch zu nehmen.
Er hat einen Termin
beim Chiropraktiker vereinbart.
* Mike seufzt. *
Wie Tag und Nacht.
Hier.
Stressbedingt.
Von der Bewegung her.
Keinen Sport mehr gemacht.
Ich gehe nächste Woche
Dienstag und Mittwoch nochmals.
Dann sollte ich nächste Woche
wieder slowly arbeiten können.
Er kann sicher damit helfen,
dass es hier lockerer wird.
Dass wir den Stress in unserem Leben
reduzieren müssen, wissen wir auch.
Allein die Behandlung durch einen
Chiropraktiker ist nicht die Lösung.
Nein!
Wir müssen unser ganzes Leben
umkrempeln. - Genau.
Die beiden müssen wohl
grundlegend etwas ändern.
Dem geschäftigen Alltag
ein bisschen Freizeit abtrotzen
und sich eine Pause gönnen,
das ist zumindest ein Anfang.
Hast du kein Spray?
- Doch.
Fuck.
- Ja.
Mich fressen sie auch schon.
Die Tampa Bay Area
ist eine Gegend mit Süsswasserseen
und vielen romantischen Plätzchen.
Ich habe Schiss,
dass plötzlich ein Alligator kommt.
Es ist so still.
(Flüsternd) Bis der Alligator kommt.
- Der kommt nicht.
Ich stinke zu sehr.
Sie haben gesagt,
man müsse vorsichtig sein,
sie seien oft unter dem Steg.
- Ja, ja.
Dort ist ein Ast.
- Das ist kein Ast ...
* Entferntes Bellen *
Schau, jetzt ist der Ast weg.
- Er ist weg.
Doch geniessen und abschalten
ist einfacher gesagt als getan.
Ich nehme mir vor ...
Wir brauchen wieder mehr Zeit
für uns, auch für die Beziehung.
Bewusster Leben.
Aber das klingt alles so gut.
Schlussendlich
hat man sich entschieden,
ein eigenes Business zu eröffnen.
Wenn man nicht hart arbeitet,
hat man auch keinen Erfolg.
Oh. Fuck.
* Akkordeonversion von Göläs
"Uf u Dervo" *
Gut neun Monate später.
Mitarbeiterin Maddie öffnet
den Waffelshop selbstständig.
Sie ist eine
von sechs Teilzeitkräften,
die die Auswanderer
mittlerweile beschäftigen.
Hopp.
Für Mike und Marina
bedeutet das viel weniger Stress.
Anstatt 100 Std. sind sie
nur noch 50 Std. pro Woche im Laden.
Ich habe mich
schon ziemlich gut erholt.
Noch nicht ganz dort,
wo ich sein will,
aber es wird von Tag zu Tag besser.
Ich bin zu 80 % der,
der ich vorher gewesen bin.
Komm, Djuni.
Acht lange Wochen konnte Mike
nicht im Waffelshop arbeiten.
Ruhe und Medikamente,
dann kommt man daraus heraus.
Und darüber reden.
Also sich wirklich eingestehen,
dass man ein Problem hatte
oder hat.
Es war zu viel für den Körper.
Egal, wie lange das schon ging.
Ich nehme an, es hat
schon in der Schweiz angefangen.
Alles hat sich immer mehr angestaut
und irgendwann war es zu viel:
Batterie leer.
Jetzt, wo es Mike wieder besser geht,
sieht er die Zeit gekommen,
neue Pläne umzusetzen.
Der 45-Jährige
möchte wieder tätowieren.
Schon in der Schweiz betrieb er
nebenberuflich ein Tattoostudio.
Für uns ist es sicher gut,
ein zweites Standbein zu haben.
Das gibt uns finanziell
etwas Stabilität.
Die Bewilligungen dafür
hat er bereits eingeholt
und auch schon
ein Ladenlokal angemietet.
Heute kann er den Raum beziehen.
In derselben Shopping Mall
wie ihr Waffelrestaurant
befindet sich
das zukünftige Tattoostudio.
Mikes neue Nachbarn:
Kosmetik-, Nagel- und Coiffeursalons.
Oh, ist das kalt hier.
Seine Arbeitstage
möchte Mike von jetzt an aufteilen.
Einen halben Tag
wird er im Waffelshop sein,
die andere Hälfte hier.
Im Waffelrestaurant soll Mike
durch Angestellte ersetzt werden.
Für mich war eigentlich immer klar,
dass ich hier mit dem Tätowieren
weitermachen möchte.
Für mich ist es
nicht irgendein Beruf,
sondern ein Hobby,
eine Leidenschaft.
Und nach meinem Zusammenbruch,
habe ich lange darauf gewartet,
dass ich wieder starten kann.
Es gibt mir die nötige Entspannung.
Das ist Abwechslung
und Freude pur für mich.
* Rumbaversion von Göläs
"Uf u Dervo" *
For here or to go?
That's yours.
Und noch etwas ist neu:
Ab sofort machen Mike und Marina
einen Tag pro Woche gemeinsam frei.
Das ist arschkalt.
Ja, es ist kühler als auch schon.
- Nicht?
Bald zwei Jahre
leben sie bereits in den USA.
Eine Zeit, die durch viel Arbeit
und den Aufbau ihres
Waffelrestaurants geprägt war.
Gehen wir nach vorne?
Für mich war immer klar, wenn wir
auswandern und ein Business starten,
dass die ersten paar Jahre
heftiger werden als in der Schweiz.
Also ich bin nicht
mit der Einstellung gegangen,
dass wir mehr Freizeit
als in der Schweiz haben.
Mit dieser Einstellung
bin ich nicht ...
(Beide) Sind wir nicht gekommen.
Aber das ist unsere Vision,
wir sind noch nicht dort,
wo wir hinwollen.
Das ist so.
Dazu gehört mehr Freizeit
und weniger Arbeit.
Irgendwann
ist es mehr Genuss als Arbeit.
Mhm.
Aber nicht jetzt,
es ist noch zu früh.
Marina und Mike wagten viel,
als sie die Schweiz verliessen.
Es hat uns nähergebracht.
Wir sind noch vertrauter als vorher.
Wir sind anders,
wir sind stärker geworden.
Man schützt sich gegenseitig,
man kennt die Schwächen des anderen.
Man greift sicher auch mehr ein
und agiert füreinander.
Man weiss:
Wenn der andere an ein Limit kommt,
bin ich dran,
jetzt muss ich hervortreten.
Ich habe gemerkt,
dass sie sehr stark ist.
Als ich ausgefallen bin,
was sie alles gemanagt
und gemacht hat ...
Das kann und macht nicht jeder.
Ja, das ist sicher eine Seite,
die ich noch weniger kannte.
Wie stark sie eigentlich ist.
Allen Schwierigkeiten zum Trotz
haben sich Marina und Mike in Florida
etwas aufgebaut.
Ich würde es zu 100 % wieder machen.
Ja. 100 %.
- Ich auch, definitiv.
Auch wenn wir jetzt nicht hier
wären, wo wir sind,
hätten wir es wenigstens probiert.
Es ist nicht so,
dass wir dann versagt hätten.
Wir haben uns für diesen Weg
in unserem Leben entschieden.
Wenn der Weg nicht stimmen würde,
hätten wir schon lange
einen anderen Weg eingeschlagen.
* Marina lacht. *
* Gemütliche Klänge *
Irgendwann ein Häuschen kaufen,
ein schönes Plätzchen einrichten.
Ich möchte irgendwann ein Boot.
Oh mein Gott.
Ich hätte lieber einen zweiten Hund.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Michaela Hoss - 2022